oh
two bladesmiths
two versions of the same blade
One winner
forged in fire weapon Showdown
Logan Keaton now it's time to send you
back to your home for just to recreate
an iconic weapon from history
the Japanese oh no oh yes
[Music]
three tests
the sharpness test the strength test
the kill test
good luck we'll see you in four days
good luck man
[Music]
my name is Logan Bracken I've always
been real crafty with my hands and I
thought hey you know what I could do
something really cool and give a lasting
gift to my family members and so from
them I've been making blades ever since
I'm making a Japanese Ono I almost
consider the width that I want it
I start noticing cracks I say I've only
got 16th of Steel left
my blade broke I've got to start over
I've got to find something to turn in
I've got some spring steel and we're
gonna go from there
music's my ears honestly I'm just happy
that I'm gonna be turning something in
my name is Keaton Goddard I've always
enjoyed working with my hands and I just
came across a video one day of a guy
making a knife out of a file and I was
like that's kind of cool so I tried it
and just kind of Grew From there I'm
taking on this competition to prove to
myself that I can do it I quit my job a
few months ago and I'm just trying to do
my own thing my blades forged out of
adcrv2 and then it's attached to a
hickory shaft and then I created some
bronze embellishments Artistry and
craftsmanship are very important to me
so I want to incorporate that
just looking really good perfect
so we use this piece of Hickory head
over to the Bell grinder I'm just trying
to get it down to a manageable size
because I don't really have a lot of
time
we're done
am I going to be making another one of
these anytime soon oh no
sharpness test
all right Logan that's an impressive cut
very clean no Jagged edges on the tubes
your weapon sir it will cut thank you
sir good job
all right keeping your turn so you ready
yep let's do this
all right keep let's talk about your
weapon here once again I have to mention
just how thin the profile of your blade
is making it Racers sharp and the cuts
are very clean overall sir it'll cut
thank you the strength first
foreign
Logan good job
your Edge is still good everything's
still tight
it's heavy
the wrap makes it a little difficult to
slide down during the chop but
everything's still tight Sharp
did a lot to that good job thank you sir
okay now you feeling good let's do it
[Music]
oh
all right Keaton good job it's a nice
and light fast easy to swing my favorite
aspect is how you have the wood going
all the way through and split up top
here your edges are still good
everything's tight good job thank you
the kill test
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Logan
this is a lot of fun
the damage that you did with your design
over here for every shop using this digs
in on the way out it guts you pretty
much opened everything and crushed
everything in its path more importantly
your honor isn't oh yes it looked cute
thank you
Keaton your turn so you ready oh yeah
let's do this
all right
foreign
let's talk about your Ono here
at first when I picked it up I was like
oh wow
that's light
then when I wielded it I was like oh yes
this thing stayed on it's solid your
edges they're sharp and that's why it
dug in very deep the overall sir your
owner was on oh yes
and it will kill thank you
all right blade Smith only one of you
can beat the forced and fire champion
and that champion is
Keaton congratulations you're the force
fire Champion Logan unfortunately your
weapon didn't make the cut David Baker's
gonna tell you why Logan you brought us
a beautiful weapon this came down to the
finer details of weight and balance and
the usability of the weapon and that's
why we're letting you go yes sir come on
forward my friend
I'm happy for Keaton but I'm
disappointed I broke my first Blade the
first two days in so I mean being able
to crank something out in 23 hours I'm
happy with it I may not be a fortune
fire Champion but I'm happy that I made
great friends
and that beautifully crafted and deadly
Ono has earned you the title of forced
and fire champion and that's the title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job brother
[Applause]
you're in pain right
excited right come on forward and Shake
our hands my friend the fortune fire
Champion I did it this experience has
been great it was definitely a challenge
the biggest thing I took away from this
was just work hard keep going no matter
what happens
in fire weapon Showdown